est ce que voulait jouer un petit jeu
patrick en faire ainsi si vous avez fait
un disque était un succès énorme qui
reprend beaucoup de chansons des années
30 qui s'appelle entre deux je vous
propose de faire une interview à métro
donc on est en 1930
d'accord je vois mal ce lundi qu est ce
que je peux vous appeler le môme bruel
way est ce que ça marche bien mais les
deux montants ça se défend
j'ai le tiercé du goût avec s'entraîner
prenez ce petit jeune n'y a pas de
talent ils sont pas seulement des points
il a fait un peu trop de convaincre mais
dont on dit qu renoir font ça vous pour
la règle du jeu c'est vrai c'est pas sûr
d'être libre
allez penser qu'il va devoir de nouveau
de la castagne que les allemands aux
noms marques et regarder tout le monde
va bien tout va mais on doute on est
bien on est peinards nouveau problème
les gens s'aiment bien non non c'est le
truc qui raconte dans les gens
voudraient que l'algérie va toujours
rester française aurait bien visionnaire
pour penser comment